all right now through Valentine's Day so
you got one week traveling couples can
get their marriage license before they
even leave Harry Reid international well
you know it's the fifth anniversary for
Clark County's pop-up marriage bureau
Laura negretti joins us live from
terminal one to tell us just how easy it
is to grab a license to get hitched tell
us more Lawrence
exactly grab your bags right here and
then grab your marriage license just
over there
the Clark County Clerk told me that over
500 people have gotten their marriage
license here just in those five years
alone each year I caught up with one of
them happy for the convenience
amazing ready to get married ready to be
Miss Warner Katie guerina and Adam
Warner got their marriage license in
minutes they filled out their permit
ahead of time saw the signs about the
pop-up and popped in to avoid the extra
hassle I think it's amazing coming from
out of state and traveling here and then
having to stay or book Ubers to
everywhere I think this is really
helpful and it was super awesome to
accommodate us and saving you know some
time and some money Clark County Clerk
Lynn Goya says it's very Vegas and
couples really seem to appreciate it you
know they like the ease of it they like
that they can get on with their wedding
celebrations instead of spending time at
the marriage license bureau she says the
wedding industry brings in 2.5 billion
dollars annually so it spreads
throughout the community in all areas of
hospitality couples pre-fill their
marriage license application bring in
their IDs and verify their information
before signing on the dotted line
they're issued a marriage license a
Keepsake and a marriage certificate oh
thank you their ceremony makes it all
official
again it's open 8 A.M to 4 P.M daily now
through that Valentine's Day cut off and
again right across from this Carousel 5
area easy peasy only in the winning
capital of the world live at Harry Reid
International Airport Lauren negretti 8
News Now yeah let's hope they're not so
excited to get the license that they
forget their luggage right
might need that might need the outfit
later
that's good stuff I mean we do
everything yep drive through Lauren
thank you thanks Lauren